thank you
[Music]
real science
the gender ideology
[Music]
push you one down
heaven
[Music]
one
one is
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
heaven
it begins on a dark night
look at this
you're not gonna find another girl like
her in a million years
[Music]
and I am not going back
let's make some money
[Music]
there's this girl
I ran away and I am not going back and I
am not going back
[Music]
oh my
God
[Music]
it's death
oh so magical
what are you doing
[Music]
wonderful time
Chase
that's who goodbye thank you goodbye
I cracked my head wow
[Music]
monkey
snake
[Music]
um
that is
beautiful songs
[Music]
connected
nobody ever does
[Music]
I understand
and here I thought you could talk to me
and then I'll just have to think of
something else
one I thought you could talk to me yeah
things won't be the same
[Music]
thank you
sideways
[Music]
foreign
my voice
[Music]
foreign
please
[Music]
we're sorry
foreign
[Music]
please
if you go on the way you started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you will be the greatest man of all time
foreign
[Music]
with science
everyone knows you're a man no one buys
a scam no one buys a scam knife
[Music]
thank you
join month club today for 89 annually
support content like this and get access
to the entire network
louderwithcrowder.com mukclub
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you better late than never I
apologize for that it is the last day of
Fremont club month and by the way people
said no you still get the free show the
free like 45 minutes to hour show yeah
yeah as far as the additional you know
50 percent of show every day the Friday
show Nick depalo show we have other
announcements coming all of that that's
where you know do uh lotto.com and none
of this happens without you so I
appreciate that you were I appreciate
your Zeal today you didn't have to crash
all of Rumble
but uh I love you though it's a good
problem to have we're growing at an
alarming rate so please do uh share post
this if you can and just in case some
people obviously know some people like
yeah it must not be happening no just
everything crashed into the service
today this happens hopefully we didn't
get hacked like Matt Walsh's Twitter
[Laughter]
honestly I hope the guy yeah it does it
yes it sucks and I hope I hope I hope
they sort it out and I hope that guy
gets sued into Oblivion so I'll be
talking about a lot today I don't know
if you know this Hunter Biden uh is uh
uh well he is racist
we'll also be talking about Sam Britton
uh the Matt Damon in sixth round of
chemo look alike and uh Vivek uh
ramaswamy ramaswamy
I don't know he just took it to Don
Lemon yesterday and that was his
breakout moment kind of like Carly
fiorina yeah uh when she had her first
debate and I don't know if you know this
Peta is the biggest euthanizer of
animals in Virginia we're going to do an
entire segment uh on what a lot of you
know that you hate Peta but you don't
know why I will give you justification
because it is righteous to hate if you
hate evil and Peta is evil question to
you is it morally wrong to have racial
dating preferences now that's not all
Hunter has
so is that wrong and then I'll have a
follow-up when we discuss uh Hunter
Biden that's what we call foreshadowing
yeah I'm a regular Orwell number two
he's here CEO Gerald how are you sir I
am doing you were angry with the
crashing I was I was swearing in text
messages which I don't do you usually do
not do because you don't want a written
record no you get hacked but everything
everything's fine which by the way uh
Tool Man in the in the WhatsApp you
might want to tone down the racial
episodes just tone it down because the
NSA is watching and in third chair today
bring it
you're gonna know this when you hear it
he is uh the best uh in the business I
say the goat as far as stand-up comedy
you can see him at the Funny Bone St
Charles Missouri tomorrow the Funny Bone
in St Louis on Saturday go to
nickdip.com to find all those tour dates
and his show is here on my club now at 5
00 p.m Eastern Nick depalo how are you
sir good what did you say about toning
down racial stuff oh I said yeah I leave
now it doesn't apply to you because you
have Sicilian in your background so it's
okay
Italian not Sicilian well and I can say
it because I have a cousin who's gay
she has Bono yes yes yeah oh gosh well I
hope she has Bono go skiing why does she
get intro music yeah everyone gets into
music yeah it worked the way it does
when they bring me up at a comedy club
yeah exactly the sound guy is like
taking a dump I get the last three
seconds of this Nugent song well it's 4
20 today
so
you just walk out you're starting your
first punchline here fever yeah okay
that's right thanks all right nailed it
by the way so it's a live show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern that's the
best way to tune in you can tune in on
Friday only on mug Club tomorrow we have
a big show uh and it's still actually
it's still free tomorrow I should say
the yeah just only on mug Club it's not
here on Rumble and uh Tool Man by the
way did you just notice that Spotlight
he changed yeah do I have a tumor what
was that
Jesus Christ
don't you love how when they do the
little little ditties
thanks thank you I appreciate it these
guys get millions of dollars in
advertising no oh oh I'm dead now yeah
by the way go and listen to Nick De
Paula one of my favorite bits is about
his moderate tavier plaque psoriasis
that becomes in our house
yeah there's no there's no beginning
mistakes just a couple pimples on your
ass
always ask your doctor yeah ask your
doctor what about what are the smiles
there's nothing we can do yeah it's just
doctor I'd like to but he's from
Calcutta he's been a minute
the good news is he's running for
president because I love that guy Vivek
uh Runners
I mean Ramadan not gonna work here no
more
so this is how you handle the media
you've seen me uh speak about this man
Andrew Breitbart I came up under his
tutelage right he was the first person
to ever run anything that I did as far
as with a conservative audience he just
took some stand up from uh old at an
improv and he was like oh I think this
would work with the audience it was more
right-leaning he was the master at
handling the media he understood their
motivations he understood what it was
that made them tick and every now and
then you see that in a candidate and
obviously right now it's all about
Donald Trump and DeSantis I'd love to
know what you think of Vivek here what
are his chances right now not you know
magic eight ball well I wouldn't bet on
it but
um he did really well so let me give you
a quick just recap and then we'll
dissect it Point by point this is what
uh Vivek Roma Swami did to Don Lemon
compare that to 1865 and
1964.65 actually I think it's insulting
to black people it's insulting to me as
an African-American I don't want to sit
here and argue with you because it's
infuriating for you to put that to put
those things together it's not right
your telling of history is wrong black
people secured their freedoms after the
Civil War is a historical fact now I'm
just studying it only after their second
amendment rights were secured you
regarding you as a fellow citizen you're
starting to hear whatever ethnicity you
are explaining to me what is it like to
be black whatever ethnicity now I would
say that Don Lemon just had to bend over
and take it but he'd like he liked it he
likes that so it's not like the
punishment has to be different bend over
not the punishment is he has to be
draped in Kathy Ireland posters
have sex with a woman yes exactly no
Gerald that would be rape
Requiem for a Dream what's wrong with
you I'm angry
I was measured before I am not now Don
Lemon was not prepared for this this is
the beauty of coming up as an underdog
he was caught completely flat-footed
that was a lot of fun to watch you
watched you watched this right to Nick I
watched it I scored it
so how is he still around this
idiot excuse my friend I mean this uh
fella PG-13 plus but oh there's no swell
teenagers curse too
um but yes I'm sorry
[Music]
you can't throw it out singular
Kevin James I don't know who it was it's
like John Jacob Jingleheimer Schmidt
everyone's like that's me watching right
now every single man in Long Island but
that's his sorry but that's his answer
to Vivek you have to be black to
understand right you can't have this
conversation unless you that is just
hacked and tired and I know and he
doesn't realize that it doesn't play
very well but the good thing is it
doesn't play well to you know the five
audience members so we're going to go
through this actually so we'll give you
a little more context kind of a
play-by-play we expect to see a lot more
from Vivek so it's time to introduce our
new segment uh the Flying V
foreign
[Laughter]
change it to the Flying tee though come
on let's see so uh let's go through a
few these clips where you have a little
bit longer here uh and by the way just
hit the share button if you're watching
on YouTube head on over to rumble if you
can but just share like comment whatever
it is we can just yeah there boom okay
there's your old demonstration yeah
there you go visual aids or is Don Lemon
calls them just AIDS just AIDS that's
why he's shrinking but he still has the
next skin uh it looks like a turtle who
came out and then went back into his
shell but a shell wasn't there anymore
he's like oh oh no lemonade
heterosexuality
[Laughter]
you and every cab driver in Queens yeah
it's another unsatisfied customer yeah
Don Lemon just is he in New York as in
New York yeah yeah is he New York or DC
anywhere there's a bath house yes
exactly in New York is if you see
something blow something that's done
just straight to all right so lemon had
a few of his go-to attacks uh he said
that as a black man which you know will
take him at his word that Rama Swami's
telling of History was infuriating
specifically because he's black John I
think we have to be able to talk about
these issues in the open regardless of
the color of our skin black Americans
today to say that compare that to 1865
and
1964.65 actually I think it's insulting
to black people it's insulting to me as
an African-American I don't want to sit
there and argue with you because it's
infuriating for you
oh gosh it's not right just write
something your telling of history is
wrong
only for black people to get guns for
black people too the Civil War black
people in this country to get freedoms a
noble mission hey you know what that
seems like it should be self-explanatory
but Don Lemon doesn't agree yeah by the
way she was writing down her recipe for
Long Island iced tea for her girlfriend
sounds like Don's doing it there's no
there's no actual iced tea what there's
no actualized tea in a Long Island
I learned something new every day no you
don't so uh Vivek actually countered
that with again this is one of those
things where they try and bring you into
identity politics he did a great job in
not doing that right he avoided that
date and this again we've talked about
the oppression Olympics we have a
leaderboard but Don Lemon thinks as a
the whitest African-American since Carl
Winslow he somehow has the ethnic card
that trumps uh pivik who is Indian
American so uh Vivek I'm pronounce that
right Vivek I think Vivek Vivek Vivek
who cares Rama Swami the good news the
good news is that he won't be offended
by me getting his name wrong he's not
that kind of guy but yeah sure whatever
it's a weird name so he countered uh
with the fact of the Second Amendment
and this is true by the way we'll give
you some historical context has helped
black Americans uh and specifically
helped black Americans earn their
freedom black people secured their
freedoms after the Civil War and is a
historical fact Don just study it only
after their second amendment rights were
secured it was not secured their
freedoms after the Civil War that is not
your you are discounting uh
reconstruction you're discounting a
whole host of things things that
happened after the Civil War when it
comes to African-Americans including the
whole reason that the Civil Rights
Movement happened is because black
people did not secure their freedoms
after the Civil War okay so this is a
perfect example here he says they didn't
meaning they didn't secure all of the
and that's true all of their freedoms
you know who else didn't get all of
their freedoms immediately Americans
After the Revolution it took a while to
get everything right you can look at any
system or there's some kind of a
revolution it takes a while but they
wouldn't have been able to start
without the Second Amendment that's why
there's amendment number one and
amendment number two and I don't know if
you know this it has consistently been
not consistently always been
historically the Democrat Party that has
tried to eliminate specifically black
Americans from utilizing their first
amendment rights and second amendment
rights but the problem that Don doesn't
seem to understand is that freed Liberty
comes after life you have to be able to
secure life first then Liberty right
because that's what the Second Amendment
did after the Civil War it's like hey
fine you can protect yourselves and be
alive to have rights at all so let's
start there and then we'll just keep
inching forward yeah well you're saying
there's no no rights it starts with the
Second Amendment yeah the first
amendment yeah supersedes even the First
Amendment I'd say Well it protects the
First Amendment you can't you can't have
the first time yeah no but that's the
thing we're the only country people say
we're the only country where we have
people can have an AR-15 we're the only
country that has the First Amendment you
don't realize that you think there's
freedom of speech we've done changed my
Minds on this it doesn't exist anywhere
else in the world it's a soft version of
freedom of speech to be clear and you
know I am by an armed society and this
is really important historically I've
always always pointed this out and maybe
it just speaks to me think about it
white people were in charge in this
country okay and of course they
purchased slaves from African slave
Traders by the way there's still slavery
going on in that part of the world in
the Middle East
white racist American founding fathers
you know the people who we demonize said
hey not only do we need to give them
rights we need to ensure that these
former slaves have guns so both parties
seek power both parties have corruption
but which one is more concerning the one
that wants to disarm the entire
population now back in the day they
specifically wanted to disarm black
people or the people who you say are
fascists who say let's give the people
who we oppress according to you the
ability to have firearms and people say
oh well should blacks have a magazine
capacity Ben no they should have
everything the white people have I think
that's a big mistake well
hindsights 2020. you ain't black
of course lemon then made it all about
race
I think we should be able to express our
views regardless of the color of our
skin we should have this debate without
me regarding you as a black man
insulting that you're regarding you as a
fellow citizen here whatever ethnicity
you are explaining to me whatever it is
I'll tell you what I am I'm an Indian
American I'm proud of it but I think we
should have this debate black white
doesn't matter I think we should have
the same content of the idea do it you
should do it in an honest way oh
I'm not a boob guy he couldn't say man
yeah he couldn't say White Plain so he
goes so you whatever ethnicity you are
explained to okay let me ask you this as
I understand it uh you guys can fact
check me if I'm wrong I believe that uh
Rama Swami is uh his parents were first
generation immigrants if I'm not
mistaken I believe it was his parents at
the furthest it was his grandparents I
believe he was born in the United States
but his parents migrated here let me ask
you this well we're playing the
oppression Olympics yeah who do you
think had it worse you think his parents
who came from India India still sucks
today to be clear or Don lemon's parents
well we say I'm talking about my
forefathers he's talking about his
parents now my point is no one has a
monopoly on oppression but Don Lemon
this is when it falls apart it's white
spleen mansplain and he's sitting across
from a man who is darker in skin color
than him I thought I had the tent off on
my TV yes Don lemon's that white and he
said whatever ethnicity you are splain
there you go that's that's how you know
that it's an ideology in Ruins at this
point but it's funny to watch Ricky
Ricardo speaking to Lucy he's got some
explaining to do I don't know where does
he come up with that it's just like why
would you even go to that point he's not
trying to Indian splain if that's what
you're trying to say to you he was
trying to tell you facts explaining he'd
say you are gay yes
Indians are going to save this country
folks I'm on the phone last night at
three in the morning with the guy in
Calcutta yeah he kind of tell me how to
get semen out of a mouse pad yeah well
that's the problem was you weren't
calling Sprint uh customer service you
were calling a sex hotline
most customer service lines are not
eight six six numbers
all right so he was first generation so
you're right his parents were for sure
sorry second generation born in
Cincinnati Ohio Cincinnati Ohio electric
Far Cry from Bombay
[Laughter]
whatever our country is bad and Don
lemon's gay all right
I would love it if it is that's a big
part like they welcome next time it's
some guy the driver and it just has a
sense his lemonade
somebody for you this for you why is
that because you are because you are a
gay and you have AIDS you know you have
the AIDS so I make design lemonade so
you understand you have eats wait a
minute
you can say that but you get upset when
I said
I didn't get upset
you said lemonades actually I'm gonna
steal it
so then Don Lemon uh he then tried to
belittle which didn't work very well uh
ramaswamy when he mentioned that the NRA
did help blacks and by the way this is
the fact check we're going to give you
uh that the NRA has helped black
Americans exercise their right to bear
arms now what Don Lemon just says is
that's not true okay now spoiler alert
he's wrong I'll explain it to you but
watch the interaction you are
discounting uh reconstruction you're
discounting a whole host of things that
happen after the Civil War when it comes
to African Americans including the whole
reason that the Civil Rights Movement
happened is because black people did not
secure their freedoms after the Civil
War and that things turned around people
would tried to change the freedoms that
were supposed to you know how they got
it they got their second amendment
rights and they actually got the NRA
played a big role in that but today down
NRA did not play it again
it's already did not play a big role
this is just historical facts the part
that I find as you say it's historical
part that I find is something there is
when you say today black Americans don't
have those rights after we have gone
through that now here's the thing John
Lemon is so incapable of arguing on the
merits that it becomes like a I mean it
becomes like a girl but here's
the thing he says he doesn't say that's
not correct he says that's a lie a lie
attributes intent now I guarantee you
that Vivid could have said hold on a
second you're lying here because Don
Lemon did lie this is just a fact that
Don Lemon disagreed with and by the way
someone can have a fact that's wrong and
it doesn't mean they're lying so right
away that's a subtle attack on character
what do you think would happen if a
white guy just did that to Don Lemon I
mean we did they're not going to do
anything because it's par for the course
as a general rule they'll decry racism
here's the truth the NRA they've done a
lot for black people by the way they
helped uh let's give you some anecdotal
examples all references are available at
lotto.com um Otis McDonald uh they
helped him legally carry his own gun in
Chicago which must be the only legal gun
in Chicago
they ruled the the Court ruled that the
Second Amendment applied to States and
it invalidated a handgun ban in Chicago
for a black man just to be clear they've
done a lot and also you need to
understand that this was important for
freed slaves at that point because there
are still worse Southern Democrat slave
holders former slaveholders who are
trying to recapture them who are trying
to Lynch them and so if you look at the
history it was very important for those
in the Republican party people on the
right who believe that they should be
free to ensure that they had the Second
Amendment as everyone else did didn't
get it all all right it's true there was
a Civil Rights Act that's true but it's
a start
and uh this is my favorite Parts Don
Lemon got so flustered I don't know if
you saw he got so flustered that uh his
makeup started running yes
you're wearing makeup two Nick wheeler
uh his powder that's my balls
which I don't by the way they're getting
that shiny you might want to go to a
doctor
um The Exchange here when his producers
got lemon mad because they were trying a
lot of you don't know that they have
earpieces and producers often try and
feed these people arguments here's in
real time black people today compared to
1964 1865 haven't made progress in part
because of the freedoms we secured and
the Second Amendment please I cannot
keep a thought if you guys are talking
to me in my ear so hang on one second so
to say that that black people say what
you said again
I can't keep a job if somebody's not
talking what was I saying what was it
and here's the thing though in his
defense yeah uh it can get very chaotic
you know when I was at Fox News for a
few years they would try
[Music]
thank you
I heard some of them yeah we were I
heard we were supposed to bleep their
audio where's the police oops uh oh
someone back there someone's getting
fired from CNN that was way off
okay I thought there was another video
clip no so
let's look at the gun control measures
that have been pushed sometimes things
are written for the bleep
but you have to rely on people
[Music]
we're angry I apologize come on guys I
apologize
I'm pissed now
so let's look at some of the specific
historical gun control measures that
were aimed exclusively at Plex from
Democrats there was a decision of the
United States versus Crookshank in 1872
which limited the rights of blacks by
the way to exercise their Second
Amendment right specifically blacks
there was a Tennessee Army Navy law in
1879 that prohibited the sale of all but
the most expensive handguns at the time
because they knew again when you're
talking about people who are slaves or
former slaves that they can't afford
those there were gun control laws across
the country by the way that existed that
were aimed at slaves and then of course
you have the Democratic cities today
that restrict law-abiding citizens
ability to keep and bear arms in places
like New York Philadelphia Baltimore
Chicago but guess what we don't talk
about black on black crime because if we
talk about that then we actually
contrast that we look at where it
converges with the mass shooting numbers
well all of a sudden the stats become a
little bit inconvenient so the Democrats
deliberately disarmed black Americans
for a very long time they're doing it
today
with the same results
there we go all right makes sense they
need to move on or anything else move on
any other uh are you still checking to
make sure the rumble server is working
and everything I think we're good yeah I
can see that Gerald is in a bad mood
he's on edge what can I do Gerald what
can I do to make units nothing you're in
a room with me and Nick depalo and
you're the Grumpy Cat
you know that's a fair point you can't
see that face he's just perspective I
needed
anything Tech wise yeah it puts me put
it on I didn't know what you guys are
talking about half the time mug club and
I have no idea
I guess that's part of them they go
where did you find your show Nick I have
no idea well people can watch people can
watch your show and they can find it
like the free part you know just like
they could on iTunes everywhere else and
then there's an extended portion yeah on
uh on Mud Club yeah so there's actually
more free content than ever and then
additional content if you want to
support it yeah absolutely coming along
and by the way that's probably a good
spot for this will make me feel better
oh talk about guns Mr guns and gear we
actually have his first video coming I
think next Thursday next Thursday wow
great have the same kind of thing you
have a little bit free a little bit
behind the paywall there so Mr guns a
little bit yeah I'm excited about that
and none of this happens without
anything even if you're like I don't
know if I want to watch an extra 45
minutes well then you get no minutes
because it all goes away
let's move on to Hunter Biden this is
always fun
how is this man still walking free Nick
I don't know but what we're about to
talk about sort of makes me like them I
have to am I supposed to have problems
that he uses racial slurs can we stop
pretending yeah that we don't talk like
this well my more still promise I'm
speaking for all of you in here he's
trying to purchase said racial slurs
that's my problem more so traffic in
them yeah well yeah yeah yeah you know
that's the issue like you can use racial
slurs you just don't want to you know
buy people
uh so okay you got a good point yes I'll
concede on that there well let's not
split here
issues with actions
actions and Yakuza based on the tech
issues you're you're at the ready here
tonight right you're good with that you
know what we got coming up all right
so an IRS special agent has uh requested
whistleblower status uh uh as it relates
to the hunter Biden investigation
my client wants to come forward to
Congress he's ready to be questioned
about what he knows and what he
experienced under the proper legal
protections attorney Mark ladle's client
is a supervisory special agent at the
IRS who's prepared to tell Congress the
investigation he's been working on has
been hampered by what he thinks his
special treatment typical steps that a
law enforcement investigator would take
were compromised because of political
considerations now let me just be really
clear there's not a whole lot new other
than he's a criminal and there's been
preferential treatment and there won't
be any investigation until you guys
actually demand it until something
that's a legitimate investigation this
is all Kabuki theater well until
somebody comes forward like this right
so that's that's a good thing that
somebody's coming forward to say hey
this is special treatment something's
going on here I'm like really right it's
like the lead but it's special treatment
based on what we already know correct
that's the issue yeah and the issue is
if you know it if we know it for credit
Giuliani showed the hunter Biden laptop
on this show for the very first time
ever on television we told you this that
we were supposed sitting here by
Assuming he's like well I have the I
have the Hunter's laptop right here I'm
like
what that is that's the laptop yeah the
FBI when they rated my uh my my
penthouse I took everything except the
laptop
[Laughter]
that's the laptop yeah I'm like have you
shown it anywhere has anyone else seen
he's like I suppose your guess is a good
minor
and you revealed it on a comedy show
Rudy
next time you do that have some hair
coloring oh my gosh and that was the end
I love them too by the way yeah he's a
fun guy he's a fun guy he's a little bit
hard to Corral in sometimes you're like
all right we gotta stay on point but uh
have you heard my new podcast no
so we'll move on here by the way hit the
rumble button hit the rumble button hit
the vibrates the whole thing and their
servers weren't working this morning
because thank you because of you but uh
last week no last day of Fremont club
tomorrow technically uh we appreciate
you signing up joining supporting and uh
let's get to the hiding
let's get to the hiding news uh the
leaked texts with his cousin
Caroline Biden
um he so there are a lot of things there
but I'm always amazed that the left
doesn't care sort of like prime minister
blackface there would be an outrage if
someone on the right did this of course
which tells you it's just about scoring
political points when people say cancel
cultures accountability culture what
they really mean it's is that it's a
catch someone doing something in a in a
landscape of ever-changing rules culture
because if there was accountability
culture if that existed well Caroline
Biden was part of these texts and Hunter
Biden referred to Asians repeatedly as
yellow
yep great band
you know how I know you're a gay Gerald
and the exchange exchanged place again
I'm not bothered by the fact that he
said yellow
it's gonna be all day he means that
chicken
the problem was what this took place
when Caroline was trying to set Hunter
up with her model friends and they may
not necessarily just be models like
Runway
the guy the guy purchased a lot of
hookers and the guy engaged we know this
with sexting with his niece who was
under age just a real germ okay at 40
something he told his niece uh I want 24
year olds because 24 year olds are easy
to impress yeah you're a very
unimpressive man that's true you do need
a 24 year old to think you're cool what
do you say oh I get Disney at my house
Disney plus yeah
I have Hulu without ads
uh all right so it's the text that's
just too the threat is too good not to
share so this is Caroline says Nicola
and Deva and Ella and Lucy will all we
will all know quality girls who are like
I am distrusting and highly highly wary
of evil oh boy and then I also have
Denise a German 26. and then Hunter
responds no to Lucy I think it's like
he's at the Golden Corral just like yes
no no Salisbury Lucy back yeah send that
one over I'll think about that one so
then she says okay so fine do you want
foreign or domestic like it's a car or a
beer I can't give you effing Asians
sorry I'm not doing it and then Hunter
says domesticated Foreigner is fine she
says I'll give you Isabella but she has
kids at an NBA ex-husband and Hunter
immediately responded no yellow
he said no yellow I should say there's
no comments
meaning he doesn't want he didn't want
yellow
and to be clear Hunter doesn't dislike
uh Asians as much as he just says he
just he doesn't want to eat where he
shits laughs
you don't want to go out I think we're
already over the crest that's destroying
yeah you don't want to go after our next
NBA player as well like I mean that's no
no if you don't want to go after a woman
who's been with an XP that's what I mean
I heard he's got a nine inch pipe I
don't think he's intimidated only if he
uses the small M M's to measure okay yes
exactly I like when she sounds like the
racist I got a German name Denise yes
Hunter goes yeah if I want somebody to
on me I'll call my dad
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
will never be seen again
laughs
by the way these are the same uh this is
these are the same guy who consistently
called his white lawyer the n-word in a
text conversation again I don't I'm not
saying that that makes someone uh the
devil incarnate what I'm saying is where
is the outrage from the left they still
have them on ABC they still give him the
Press tour they still supported his book
it's hey people make mistakes Megan
Kelly keep in mind Megan Kelly was
canceled because when she was on I
believe it was ABC or NBC NBC it was NBC
she said I don't look I think there's a
difference between blackface When We
Were Young For example Halloween we'd go
out dressing up as Diana Ross not
because we were trying to do blackface
because we loved Diana Ross we looked up
to Diana Ross is that is that such a bad
thing that was why she was fired this
guy uses the n-word and is purchasing
yellow sorry not yellow prostitutes
as a kid Megan Kelly with a bone through
the nose yeah
that was unfair yeah exactly what the
Supreme's role it was a little
professional wrestling it's just not
right yeah not right she also didn't
have to do a Minstrel show well it
wasn't necessary and I don't remember
Diana Ross ever saying yes sir boss no
balls
Mistral or I think you said Minstrel I
said Minstrel
is which one you're just in a mood no
that's fair
speaking of Moody uh and not speaking of
menstrual Sam Britton uh the
kleptomaniac and Matt Damon and sixth
round of chemo look alike also X by
nuclear waste Chief he's just been
ordered to undergo a mental health
evaluation oh nice right good I mean
who'd have seen this one coming so
here's a quote from New York Post
Britain who was accused of stealing
luggage on at least two separate
occasions no no no he was on camera
stealing luggage yes I was like he's
wearing the lady's underwear when he was
arrested they're acting like it's clue
like no we know he's still luggage yeah
who did it yeah Britain in the midst of
mustard at terminal seven exactly it's
like well we suspected that he stole
luggage when we caught him on camera and
then when he uh told us I steal luggage
and took us to his stolen luggage closet
it's really a spare room it's not even
our suspicions were confirmed so stole
luggage on two separate occasions has
agreed to undergo a mental health
evaluation as a part of a Minnesota
adult diversion program
um he has also had to write an apology
to one of his victims what what is he
five I don't know and he just pushed his
sister
[Music]
foreign
but you can address the reality of it
and so then you've ever heard the term a
pound of defense is worth ten thousand
pounds of cure or a pound of prevention
yeah that should apply here but instead
we keep we just keep rocketing to the
end of this cliff and then we're
surprised when we fall off so here's a
video actually may 2021 to give you an
example Britain now having to undergo a
psych evaluation or mental health
evaluation participated in a webinar
about mental health in the time of
something something covered that's how
they always shoot hornet
[Music]
sorry honest mistake uh sorry I think we
have the real clip yeah I got it here's
Sam Britain Mental Health
my why of mental health is because mine
isn't always great we before everyone
joins us
by connecting the thoughts I'm surviving
with a smile that is my mental health
right now it is it is not
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so here's the thing just to be clear
he's being made to undergo a mental
health evaluation
just because we have to in the spirit of
full disclosure for stealing the luggage
that is all he is undergoing a mental
health evaluation for yes and nothing
else
[Music]
let's see
foreign
just
the luggage
all right I'm stunned the first time I
saw that Montage remind me of Rocky one
you don't want to see what he does at
the top of the capital
and all the way up them well he Pogo
sticked up and then just uh yeah I mean
MIT too I mean this is a perfect example
the idea of higher education and you end
up like that I know borderline genius
sanity but he seems like a stupid
[Laughter]
No cameras at a carousel with the
LaGuardia
pretty sure there are and by the way you
might want to make sure that there are
no cameras at LaGuardia because I saw
I've heard the rumors
um
also suck Peter this is something that's
important because they're now and I love
this though that Budweiser is getting it
from all sides you know they're being
boycotted by conservatives and by the
way some people are saying actually
their stock value has gone up uh over
well here's the thing this is not the
sales are not going to be coming in
until you know the next quarterly
earnings report they're not going to be
coming in until the next sales call
which is probably going to be in August
right now this is about people basically
trying to plump up the stock the sales
are going to reflect the long-term
future of Budweiser there are a lot of
games that they can play especially as
it relates to ESG but if you look at
what's happening across the country when
you're looking at bars when you're
looking at places that are no longer
stocking it okay keep the pressure on I
don't care what some Republicans tell
you but they're also getting it from the
other side from Peta because Peta is
furious about uh the Clydesdales
commercials really so uh especially
after Budweiser just tried to win you
back without apology
foreign
[Music]
Belgium found in a community
where a handshake is a sure contract now
with Don Lemon means more than that rude
and for those who found opportunity in
Challenge and hope that was Joe
Scarborough
raised by Generations
[Music]
again
remember
[Music]
oh come on
what did I miss bigger than beer
beer this is the is the story of the
American Spirit
really what does that even mean and by
the way to a lot of people out there who
are you know the whole like I go to
NASCAR those people and I do mean this
the middle Americans who are sometimes
just know Michelob is also
Anheuser-Busch Bush light I've seen some
people say yeah I'm pouring out my Bud
Light and I got my bus
you have to be just bothered to do a
little bit of research you're required
to be responsible as a consumer today
okay that is required of you yeah
those are beautiful animals are those
Clydesdale
[Music]
super
and by the way those Clydesdales that
get treated unbelievably these are these
are show horses yeah right these are not
so Peter's wrong in all facets but
here's something that you may not know
okay you know they suck but you may not
know why you absolutely despise Peta and
they have a storied history of actually
killing animals and also wanting to take
away your pets everything about Peta is
wrong and when you understand how much
money they have and how they play a role
also in the environmental lobbying
organizations which also by the way this
is all connected has played a role in
what your dietary guidelines are which
leads you uh to making worse Health Care
decisions and lead you to having worse
Health parameters and outcomes you
understand why this matters Peter should
have no influence Unfortunately they
have far more than you know so Peter is
now protesting Anheuser-Busch for its
use of the big horses this is the
jumping off mode
[Music]
Budweiser has blood on its cans whatever
so
Donuts cans so does there's dates at the
end of the night
[Music]
so Peta tweeted instead of raising a
glass for Budweiser's 90th anniversary
we're raising awareness of their cruel
horse mutilation by passing out 90
bottles of Ripple white ale look
remember that they chose the crappy name
remember Ripple blonde was in top secret
that was the wine that burned down the
glass just it was you'll Ripple blondes
and the glass just as it dissolves but
here's the thing that crop Tails by the
way just so you understand that's
there's sometimes there's a purpose for
that just to be clear I get it I'm not a
huge fan of it so for example uh like
Joe Lewis he's a dog Argentino they
often crop the ears of the duck why
because they were bred to go out and
hunt and protect the farms in Argentina
from war and cougar you know what's
worse than having cropped ears having a
cougar clot and rip it out now Joe Lewis
doesn't hunt cougar her bore so I don't
need to crop his ears the reason they
often crop Tails they do this with
horses people can correct me if they're
you know equestrians out there is that
crap gets stuck in there it gets matted
and sometimes it also becomes a problem
if they're in a pen when they're
traveling and gets caught it's for them
it's for the better health of the animal
it's like a cruel it's like a
ponytail yes exactly although in many
instances from I don't speak for
first-hand experience sometimes it's
nice to have a handle liar
and you know it
so let's go through though everything
that is wrong with Peta and
unfortunately you may think that it
doesn't affect you but it does to a very
large degree so let's go through five
fast facts fast fact number five
so Peter uh they kill a lot of animals
uh and the 25 last years alone peta's uh
Virginia shelter killed 50
000 animals the Virginia Department of
Agriculture uh they actually identify
the shelter in Norfolk as quote the
single largest killer of animals in the
state even surpassing the previous
record held by Michael Vick's barbecue
this is one thing that they don't they
don't they you wouldn't assume that Peta
euthanizes animals not only do they do
that and I'm not against the
euthanization of animals just to let you
know sometimes it is necessary sometimes
it is Humane but they do it at an
exponentially higher rate than other
places whose job it is is to re-home
animals
this is the thing that's important to
note yeah and uh uh I think Nick it
doesn't matter let's move on let's see
what happened it's safer
you had something to run through that
never mind I can't see I'm blind
am I supposed to be watching this map
I was trying to cue you on your own joke
that was hilarious you think I can
remember what I said to you an hour ago
I don't think so no
oh my God we'll bring it into the scrap
yard show tomorrow behind the paywall so
in 2022 alone Peter killed over 2 000 uh
dogs and cats okay just to give you an
idea they had a 74 kill rate in their
shelter yeah okay and a 2.1 adoption
rate
now here's that doesn't matter unless
you have the contrast right the average
Virginia Animal Shelter they have a 5.2
percent kill rate and a 74 adoption rate
so a 74 kill rate for PETA versus a five
percent kill rate
for another animal shelter in the same
state well just just to add a little
context on the cats some have said that
that's a good start some yes some have
said just saying not all animals are
equal yes it's a higher kill rate than
Chris Kyle in Iraq
I asked a lady at the airport she had
her kid I'm not Kenya
yesterday had her little daughter run a
lease and I asked if it was a rescue
after you were called out what happened
she goes what and I want nothing really
she didn't laugh she looked like she had
a sense of humor but she didn't no no of
course I guess the tie-dye T-shirt said
in the five o'clock Shadows oh you met
Samuel you got to stop meeting people at
the carousel at LaGuardia
so in 2014 uh in response to peta's uh
in response to peta's killing and all
Virginia Pat actually passed SB 130 1381
I think one one three eighty one that
defined a private animal shelter as
quote a facility operated for the
purpose of finding permanent adoptive
homes for Animals this bill might as
well read we're looking at you Peter
yeah they promptly lobbied against them
yes Peter lobbied against the bill so
they not only kill at an astronomical
rate they then use their many many many
tens of millions of dollars in funding
to continue killing at an astronomically
High rate
they love I wish I loved anything as
much as Peter loves killing animals
but it starts with a lie it starts with
this premise that well everyone wants to
treat animals better of course but I
thought I mean I've always thought of
PETA as being the place that animals are
saved that there's re-homed that they're
put out in some pasture to live Wild and
Free and happy for the rest of their
lives most people think Peta does two
things they save animals and they throw
red paint on ladies with fur coats well
I know they kill animals and then they
do the second one so one out of two
ain't bad funny Billboards every once in
a while like if a shark ate you it's I
guess it's fair or something like that
they always they go too far yes in the
80s they were upset because they were
using monkeys
to try to find a cure for AIDS right and
I said if hooking a monkey's brain up
their car battery is going to save
somebody from dying AIDS I got two
things to say red is positive in the
black
and there's a tag to that joke I can't
remember I agree I agree let's go to uh
fast fact number four
[Music]
from Peter
here's something you may not know here
was their treasure chest in 2019 their
budget 55 almost 56 million dollars oh
my goodness it's been another 16 million
dollars in assets only seven million
dollars in liabilities so and then
they're fun to balance at the end of it
was something like eight million dollars
the point is they have an unbelievable
amount of cash here's where they spend
their money PETA International
Grassroots campaigns which may include
what you just saw with Budweiser
throwing red paint on fur coats 15
million dollars public Outreach and
education 32 million dollars just to be
clear that also involves lobbying these
people have a when people about
the NRA first off none of it comes close
to the teachers unions why aren't we
talking about Peta and we'll get to how
that affects the American uh health and
dietary associations the American Health
Association our heart association all of
these things are interconnected and it
all stems from secular humanism uh
research investigations and rescue 23
million dollars a cruelty-free
merchandise program I don't even know
how you do that when you're killing 74
of your animals well it's not cruel yeah
I guess
Sarah Mclaughlin here make up seven
million yes exactly
I mean they couldn't extend the concert
but when they had Melissa Etheridge it's
like I don't know why they have all
homes
now yeah there was an expense in there
for 325 dollars for one bathtub to drown
the animals yes
[Laughter]
Carol you're Savage here's something
else you may not know I agree about
pitas right you're talking about Peta
here's Fastback number three
I missed yeah actually a lot of people
think Peta is for pet owners
Peter doesn't believe in pet ownership
if you look at Peta originally they had
a radical stance and it's been
reiterated today they don't believe that
you should be able to own pets but they
don't really talk about that so much
okay the pet ownership that uh this is
from 1983 too the cat like the dog must
disappear we should cut the domestic cat
free from our dominance by neutering
neutering and more neutering until our
pathetic version of the cat ceases to
exist this is and what they'll do is
they'll do this and then of course
[Music]
from this
why why would you do that Joe Lewis is
fine he's right here yeah Joe Lewis come
on over here
he's happy guys come on oh he is happy
yeah hi all right
see that looks like fun no he just did
one and he's out
that's a good boy oh oh now
[Laughter]
oh my God
you know what this equipment costs
show me he looks happy okay
guys he doesn't need to be a part of
that commercial that was ridiculous
nobody's sticking pencils in his eyes
and stuff well you had the comment
before about you know getting his ears
on yeah yeah well by the way he just
blew an intern off their feet
we have good insurance for a reason
folks yeah yes so uh let's go to fast
fact number two
got him this is going really well uh
yeah actually Steve Steals and kill
did you know that
that's in my house
I'm gonna you that one shut the
up
anyways go ahead sorry I thought you
were making another wife joke
not enough Strays we got to go in the
backyard I can't do it no you can't I
love the way yes yes of course so
someone help me so
they steal and kill pets here's two Peta
Associates right they actually this is a
story that you may have heard of all the
references are publicly available they
took a family's pet from the property
and euthanized the animal on the same
day
so here's from the guardian two women
affiliated with Peta went on to zarat's
home and took their unattended and
Unleashed chihuahua named Maya Maya was
put down later that day uh the family
sued Peta and won 49 000 and of course
Peta denied the allegations calling it a
terrible accident that was all they said
I thought they blamed the Chinese
restaurant yeah
they also run a Chinese restaurant
that's part of their operating budget
it's it's research we need one more for
the quota all right I'll be back yes
this little yapper down the streets had
it coming I said I said no MSG
Chihuahua oh
why would I say that I don't know I
thought it was weird too
what do we do now your guess is as good
as mine shihu and broccoli don't waste
it tastes very good yes it's uh it's a
Pomeranian beef
did you say Mongolian uh-huh yeah uh so
we'll go with that Here's the final fact
that you guys need to know
that this affects not just Peta but all
these secular humanistic or humanist
organizations who don't want you not
only to eat meat or drink milk or eat
eggs uh they want you to eat bugs and
like it this is a part of international
government agreements and trees this is
what they're pushing you toward they
don't want you to have choice so here's
an example of New York city mayor Adams
uh actually just echoing the sentiment
declaring war on meat and dairy one in
every five metric tons of carbon dioxide
our city emits comes from food but all
food is not created equal
the vast majority majority of food that
is contributed to our emission crisis
lies and meat and dairy products does it
a fact doctor you know that they plant
plant power diet is better for your
physical and mental health and I am
living proof of that but the reality is
finding out it is better for the planet
I am proof of that you've heard of
endomorphs and ectomorphs I am a body
type of turtle
actually what did she say smorgy booger
I don't know why I don't know why he is
[Laughter]
wrong it's not correct just to be clear
and it's also worse for the environment
to be clear when you understand what
happens if everyone moves to plant-based
diet okay so let me kind of lay this out
for you A lot of people and I want you
to conduct this experiment at home uh
hit the like button by the way if you're
watching on YouTube and comment below if
you knew about this
uh let me get to it and then I'll ask
you the question because there's some
information that you need yeah you
should get off YouTube so a lot of our
dietary guidelines are not based on
Health at all you just heard that right
there right that was a perfect example
encapsulation it's about politicization
and that stems from the idea of the
environment and what is seen as
Progressive so I'd like you to do this
experiment okay my net diary I believe
is the biggest uh place where you can go
in and log your food and your calories
okay
so I went in and did this myself so I
went in and I entered in a ribeye steak
so rib eye steak from a farm you know
good ranchers from a farmer I know it
comes from I know the nutritional
profile the rating
was a d That's wrong okay a whole egg
rating was a B minus
goat milk that a lot of people don't
like but it's about as healthy B minus
now let's contrast that with Honey Nut
Cheerios it's an A minus are you serious
Lucky Charms is a B plus I'm saying let
me go even worse Cheetos is a bee what a
should be an a eggs and goat's milk were
B minus and Cheetos are a b and rib eye
is a d
oh my God and they use what the American
Heart Association and the the Academy of
nutrition and uh dietetics okay these
are the people who they use as a
reference point for these guidelines
that you follow that Mr Adams mayor
Adams believes is healthier well let me
give you a little bit of a back story on
this on the American uh uh the American
Academy of nutrition and dietetics it's
really long let's just go with an
acronym in 2019
uh major Global food and beverage
companies they committed to this who
trans fat pledge well by the way too
it's not the same as trans it's just yes
exactly well okay let me give you let me
give you first a few couple of examples
okay the American Heart Association all
right then you look at the American
Association of dietetics and nutrition
these people are funded largely by a
huge amount of funding comes from
pharmaceutical companies I'm not saying
big Pharma man what I'm saying is it
comes from these companies as well as
snack food companies it does defy reason
and everything that we know when you
think hold on a second a rib eye from a
local Farm I would be better off on a
diet of Cheetos and Lucky Charms than
say ribeye steak and whole eggs that is
what they are telling you that is what
they advise and by the way these people
are in agreement with Peter it all stems
from this neo-environmentalism you can
go back and look at McDonald's
McDonald's used to use beef Tallow and
they're in their fries yeah and what
happened they said well actually that's
really bad for your health it's bad for
your heart saturated fat but there was a
subtext there too there were a bunch of
environmental lobbyists groups who said
no no we should use hydrogenated seed
oils turns out that's worse for you than
beef Tallow and so now they've decided
to go to other oils that aren't trans
fats but aren't animal fats so this is
actually something right now that they
have applied um this pledge the who to
phase out industrially produce trans fat
from the global food supply by 2023.
here's the thing
the neo-environmentalist group doesn't
want them to do that why because the
replacement because it can't be beef it
can't be Tallow it can't be that
saturated fat but trans fats are really
bad for you would largely be palm oil
and that is what oh it's bad for the
environment it's bad for the environment
and the American Heart Association by
the way who also advises the advises of
the World Health Organization they
receive 6.2 million dollars from
AstraZeneca Pfizer 767 thousand dollars
uh verily which is Google life sciences
5.4 million dollars now I know what
you're saying that no they also get a
bunch of small donations sure but if
they have membership dues and you're
paying let's say 20 30 a year yeah and
they have a pharmaceutical company
paying 6.2 million dollars a year to
whom are they going to be beholden or if
it's PepsiCo to whom are they going to
be beholden that's why you have your
diet calculator tell you that Cheetos
are A-Okay but you know what stay away
from that New York strip that could clog
your arteries so let me let me get this
straight in this segment
it's good to eat animals
it's better for you than eating Cheetos
I think that's the takeaway yeah I like
it I do believe in an animal-based diet
is probably the best diet that you can
eat well they lose we win yeah no I mean
honestly I think that as far as being
healthy and that's primarily what it is
is meat and then you can have some
vegetables we should not be eating
nearly as much not because of gluten
okay I'm not a just
all of this crap wait we know trans fats
are bad for you we know that now it's
been acknowledged even internationally
but environmentalist groups and groups
like Peterson no no hold on a second
screw humans we know that we're giving
them all kinds of chronic health
problems and and potentially damaging
foreign
what's the term in English part of Palms
okay because I'm thinking uh yeah the
French arms that's a lot of jokes
artichokes it's the same thing right oh
is it I I don't know when you said what
happened what just happened here I
thought it was religious The Palms you
get on Thompson oh I think we all just
had a stroke we all got married I think
I caused it
you were saying artichokes well look a
while back they had a they had an
opportunity to kind of decide on what we
were going to focus on for for food
Health right so to see like what is
going to be healthy what are we going to
focus on it was calories that we chose
instead of sugar and carbs based that it
was saturated fat yeah then it moves to
this and it's like guys you're missing
the boat on all of this as parents when
you go right now and you're looking at
Food most of the time you don't turn it
over and look at the calorie count in it
because that's usually pretty low for
kid stuff you look at how much added
sugar is in it because you know what it
does to your child immediately not just
long-term Health but you know they're
going to be bouncing off the walls yeah
so you're telling me those cereal brands
turn that box over yeah look at how much
of your daily intake of carbohydrates is
in there look how much added sugar is in
there look how much processed crap is in
there right give me that steak well they
even Changed by the way internationally
they've acknowledged that cholesterol is
not nearly as an important of a marker
as like C-reactive protein inflammation
which is increased dramatically far more
by insulin resistance by over intake of
sugar and not by simply saturated fat
right now you don't want to become
dogmatic and eat only saturated fat like
some of these carnivore diet you're like
all I eat is I just eat the fat from the
steak and I need nothing else I haven't
taken a dump in four months so look
eating a balanced diet that includes
animal fat your body needs it your body
needs cholesterol we know that now to
produce hormones so think you can't come
up with a more brilliant way to create
especially on 420. to create a
generation of dumb malnourished weak
chronically ill-depressed people get rid
of life-giving foods under the guise of
environmentalism I don't know throw more
weed at it
I love it yeah no sorry Nick what reason
Oh I thought you're about to say he said
yeah I was I was going to say how about
as far as the information about
nutrients in the package let's get rid
of the I don't get rid of the metric
system yeah well people don't know what
it's about 1500 milligrams of sodium is
that's true oh yeah salt yes that'll
kill you not that much but the metric
system yeah seriously what is that about
well actually what would you do if you
weren't doing grams or if you weren't
doing milliliters you put you know what
I have noise ounces you put it yeah I
guess you could put it too small I think
it's too small there's two I don't know
I was doing the math in my head I'm like
could we do that but is it not okay we
could that is metric is it nice it is
metric it's very stupid yeah well it's a
very stupid system the metric system
actually it probably makes more sense I
don't know I have no idea I was raised
in Canada where they said we use the
metric system that's right and I say
okay how tall are you yeah six
one point one meter I'm like see you're
full of crap they're not even consistent
with it I get it if they just weren't
Pricks about it I'd be fine with it so
this is the point where we're talking
about Peta and they're protesting
Budweiser which is fun you know break
off the pool cues let them have tryouts
but you need to understand what's
happening beneath the surface the
influence of it says a war of ideology
of secular humanism when they have
acknowledged that this will harm people
right continuing to feed them a bunch of
hydrogenated uh vegetable oils that
occur nowhere in nature and if
unilaterally been condemned as bad for
your heart is it but no no but we care
more about the environment and they do
all of this under the guise of you know
just caring about animals hmm
which is uh nice I guess they care about
killing
[Music]
all right guys stop he's fine he was
fine a minute ago I I told you he's okay
you guys do to him I mean he's
absolutely fine yes he's out there all
right he just attacked the new intern
I didn't know well hey look before
before we go any further I have some
really good news what really what are
you just are you fake getting my hopes
up or is there actually good news
BuzzFeed shuts down it's news division
hey there you go they shut down their
news division we're using that term a
little Loosely these days yeah exactly
yeah a bunch of gifts of cats holding
hands celebratory music please yeah can
I get something that's happy there you
go there you go we have a little bit of
not music that's not music it's just a
little bit of confetti to people
listening on audio that are going no
they can't all be gems
I didn't know they still had a news
division uh BuzzFeed that's when you
know you're a loser it's like it's like
someone retiring and people going you're
still around
wouldn't that happen to a better man
Buzz news feed they had a news division
let me guess they had budgeting problems
what's next the weather
next is going to be CNN's going to shut
down Don lemon's show like well we just
don't have the budget for you lose
he's black and he's gay you can't fire
that yeah the report says that BuzzFeed
is shutting down it's news Vision a part
to effort to cut 15 of its Workforce 15
of its Workforce Elon Musk cut 80 which
tells you where their priorities are
it's 15 that they need to cut down so
the first thing we're eliminating is
news
what's the other 85 I'm not up on
opinion that's probably HR HR yes HR all
their writers running handsy yeah put a
dent in that yeah that's like Fox News
it's like okay we have about 15 to news
and we had about 75 percent to silencing
all the women Roger elscropped so
yes he does and soft hands
that's Shepard Smith
oh I guarantee you him and Don Lemon are
hanging out at Langan Oh No Doubt like
did you see what I did with Vivek today
yeah you were just such a little I
loved it
we don't need viewers no
no rated people watching and stuff
I do the news for me I don't care what
people think I just do it for me this is
for me
matter of fact I prefer people don't
watch that's why I do what I do
I've been fired Don which by the way
we're not going to be shutting down our
news division here because uh well we
it's all Blended I guess we don't really
necessarily have a news division but we
make all the references publicly
available for you and this is the last
day today on Rumble if assuming the
servers are still up uh where you can
get free mug Club month tomorrow we are
still going to be doing the show it's
free on mug Club we're going to continue
the show here on Rumble today taking
chat Thursday and by the way we'll show
you how you can join mug Club in the
future just hit that one button if
you're on Rumble there's really a button
you click and you'll never have to miss
a show but we appreciate that you've
joined us here this month just to be
clear some of
free show like that here on Rumble and
YouTube the first hour of the show but
we've given you the extended portion of
the show for free and none of it exists
for those who don't uh support us
through mud Club we're incredibly
excited and grateful to all of you who
have signed up and we're looking forward
to seeing more of you um sign up and if
you're still looking uh for a reason as
to why uh Devin out there actually I
guess put together this night nice
little nice little number for you and
after that it's going to be YouTube
rope
most of our thought leaders will speak
out on what's Happening
tone it down just enough so they don't
get demonetized
let alone Band YouTube go ahead remove
us we are here to lead a mass Exodus off
your platform
it's time to turn it up it is time to
match intensity why can't we not
come if you're acting
one and that's why your Victory is your
listeners and viewers Victory Club
readers say there's a market
where Harper
lateral cooperation between media and
between the government that to me is the
biggest threat Muhammad Ali wasn't just
an impressionable young racist in his
personal life he even profited from
using blatant racism best way to stop a
home Intruder is that
third time's coming you Clockwork elf
demon gay frog that's what I've been
saying it's time right now to fact check
the fact checkers
a lot of other people say he's even
worse
now is the time for you to be both
anyway
we kept the Mud Club